the only person jumping at this
trampoline Center in Tamworth is the
owner's daughter Polly has a space
designed for hundreds to herself at this
business like so many it will not be
bouncing back fast the prime minister
says some hospitality businesses may be
able to open by July but owner cliff
thinks that may be optimistic lockdown
has already cost four hundred thousand
pounds in lost revenue he says the
sector needs long-term support it saw
the devastating effect on the business
operationally I have no concerns about
reopening with social distancing on
trampolines but financially I think it
could be quite devastating for us
because we'd probably be looking at
around half of our usual income but
possibly with increased staffing costs
construction and manufacturing workers
are now being actively encouraged to
return to work immediately to help me
start the economy and some shops
currently considered non-essential may
be able to open from June the first this
garden center had been hoping to open
this week the Prime Minister offered
them no clues but they have been working
on measures to make it safe including
limiting customers to 60 at a time
mapping out a one-way system and
directing screens at tills guidelines on
how to make all workplaces covert secure
are being worked on but unions have
questions I'm very skeptical about
moving from the sound byte to the very
practical detail plan that's needed by
employers in order to return people to
work and to return them safely with
confidence
while more workers are being asked to
return they're being urged to avoid
public transport social distancing means
that commuter services like this one
will only be able to run at a fraction
of their normal capacity was not yet
clear as if people will be advised to
wear masks or face coverings and before
many will be able to get back to work
they'll need their children to be back
at school which may begin for primary
school years 1 and 6
next month what might be returned look
like we've also got to bear in mind that
these students have been out of
education for some time now so it's not
just coming straight back into what we'd
regard as the norm
we've still got to adopt with social
distancing but unless we have a time
scale it makes it incredibly difficult
for us to predict Oh easy planning
together the impact on children is one
of many unknowns in this pandemic but
for education like the wider economy
recovery will only come one careful step
at a time
Paul Kelso Sky News in Tamworth